the most complicated simulations that
are currently being done in the world
are being done using the direct
computers Derek stands for distributed
research using advanced computing and it
is a national facility for theoretical
astrophysics and particle physics and it
is based in Leicester Cambridge Durham
and Edinburgh and we have five different
machines at those four locations the
node that's at Leicester has about four
and a half thousand computing cores and
so a typical family computer might have
four of those cores so immediately were
a thousand times more powerful in terms
of the number of cores but the real
thing that's makes us more powerful is
the way the computer is connected
together this is what we do with those
cores they are it's called an all too
old cluster so it has a lot more
connections between the individual cores
on the system so that they can talk to
each other much better so if you just
took a thousand home computers and put
them all in a room they wouldn't be
nearly as powerful as the system that we
have here
as we offered these are basically highly
efficient parallelized fire system
storage because we've got however many
of these completely
few jobs I think it's running age to
them and each of them could be wanted to
access files on here so although it's
presented as looking like
so specific science questions need
different types of computer architecture
we call the Lester node the complexity
system and the reason is we're looking
at some of the most complex physical
systems in the universe each of the
nodes they're all housed in Sassy's and
out of them come lots of communication
cables and that's really the heart of
what makes it such a powerful computer
is all of these communication cables
between the different nodes this is a
broken one so I'm not too bothered about
the with the operating system on there
scientists or researchers would submit
jobs that job said - that we should get
run on one of these complete notes
whenever these are booted up that's
reconfigured there's a lot of them here
so it's potentially a lot of work
keeping this going but the system is
very clearly configured so I could take
that out right away put a new one in
slot it back in turn it on and within 10
minutes it will be booted up
reconfigured by the system
so we're not wasting time poking around
for doing about the operating system
it's running scientific limits Redmond
under there we've got heat sinks with
the CPUs no no we've been it's been a
very stable system and so we've had
occasional minor issues with individual
cores but very very few of them have had
to be replaced it's been very stable
we've got pretty much Next Day Delivery
push it back in as I say within 10
minutes they'll be back
yes yes because you can never you can
never find an allen key when you want
them
it's really just computer and in some
ways it's not so different from the
computer
the networking is different there are
more than one network connection and
there's InfiniBand and a control network
and so on virtual switch we can turn a
Natasha she'll that sassy and that sassy
or all chassés or individual blades
again it's the clever bit really is the
if you had an orchestra with lots and
lots of instruments you've still got the
conductor the firm who's kind of keeping
everyone do that's what the log-in nodes
do so they make sure that they keep
track of which chords are working if any
of them breaks the login nodes will know
about it and they're it's the login
nodes where the scheduler runs for
everybody's simulation so if I want to
start a simulation I put it in the queue
and it's the login nodes control where
it's going to go and they'll also make
sure that it has access to the right
amount of memory I have to make sure the
data at the end are transferred to
somewhere safe because at the end the
computer will just shut down the shut
down the job and it'll wipe the round
head for the database is replicated
between them it will be full right now
we can have a look at the show jeweler
and see who's doing what
I've logged into one of the head notes
here so this is what basically what a
user would see when they log in and you
can see the jobs here that people are
running there that's one of our PhD
students
why PHP
there's a lot of work going on this
simulation here's a cache one that's
looking at a smaller galaxy around the
Milky Way and looking at what happens
when a supernova so when a star explodes
what that does to the gas distribution
in that galaxy so what Claire is doing
is some simulations about in the very
early universe the job is actually
running on 16 processors at the moment
so although it's only a two-hour job
it's using because it's using 16
processors that equates to 32 hours of
CPU time but it's only taking two hours
of real time so you're getting results
back much quicker it's basically that
the parallelization yeah
so what you'll gather is we will be able
to make movies of what's happening but
the really interesting thing is to study
the properties of the gas that had that
changes with time because
to understand you have to look at the
galaxies in the simulation and compare
them to the real galaxies that we see
are
we're trying to understand how stars
form of those galaxies these are from
the group in Exeter who are running
simulations of star formation and the
movement of gas in a galaxy like the
Milky Way to have the Gaussian bowls in
the disk
without what is nearly finished but it
will have taken a very long time so
these these are long jobs and the thing
to notice is you have all of these jobs
running at the same time and given that
there's about four four and a half
thousand cores it means every one hour
that the system is running it's doing
about four thousand hours of work so
that's the speed-up that you can get but
it's also a trade off because if you
spread the job too thinly each poor is
not doing very much so they spend too
much time talking to each other another
enough time working I didn't want to say
that
so these kind of jobs would be
impossible to do on the normal desktop
because they would take so long to do
each individual run that we wouldn't be
able to understand what was going on